what is up guys my name is channel
welcome to episode 17 of 30 game
programming in Java alrighty now that's
gonna be a quick episode because it's my
birthday today 10th 10th of December so
I basically don't have time and I'm busy
all weekend so I can't make a long
episode so yeah I'm sorry for you guys
who really wanted to have a long episode
but next week and also there'll be a
midweek episode for the Express series
if you missed the first Express episode
then click on the screen right now
there'll be an annotation to take you to
that video and you can check it out
because it's cool anyway so basically
what I wanted it what I'm gonna do today
is true like small things first of all a
bunch of you guys have been saying that
well when I launched the game I can't
move straight away I actually have to
click on the screen and then move and
that's that's sort of a problem but it's
easily fixed I should have done this
earlier but I just forgot I guess if you
go into the wild running loop under
underneath everything or well wherever
you want just type a request focus okay
and now if you launch it then it will
automatically actually move and you
actually don't have to click on the
screen to activate it
so that's the first little thing
actually this episodes are really short
anyway the other thing is I actually
forgot to do this last week and that is
if we crouch we actually move the same
like speed as if we were walking and
when you crouch you want to sort of move
slower obviously so what we did what we
need to do essentially just decrease the
walking speed so if we go into
controller then we've got like this
we've got this double we got this walk
speed variable and it's set to 0.5 at
the moment so all we need to do is if we
are crouching if we are crouching then
we need to set our walk speed equal to
like I don't know 0.2 is pretty nice so
now if we launch it run it then that's
walking and then if we Crouch as you can
see we walk a lot slower and that's
realistic and awesome alrighty so what
are we at 2 minutes
well boy this is this is funny um
alrighty guys I really don't have time
really sorry I'm actually not getting
paid for this at the moment that's the
other thing I wanted to mention it sorry
for all of you guys who will like make
more episodes stuff like that I only
have time to make an episode one
can okay but I'm trying to do one every
Sunday as you can see I am so I'm sorry
this time it's gonna be a short one but
next time we're gonna start on walls
obstacles all of that stuff and that's
gonna be really huge so it will probably
have like a at least a half-hour episode
tomorrow so not tomorrow next Sunday
okay guys so uh that's it see you guys
later bye